[Musique]
la 20e édition du challenge des
créateurs a été lancée ce mardi 10
octobre au village de corail une matinée
dédiée au speed casting où les 130
candidats ou un tour de rôle présenter
leur projet de création d'entreprise
devant les 24 jurés il avait huit
minutes chacun parce qu'à signer la
deuxième phase du concours la première
fois c'était l'inscription sur le site
internet de la collectivité pour ce
challenge pour la vingtième année et le
spi de casting c'est la rencontre des
candidats qui peuvent défendre leur
projet de création d'entreprise devant
un jury composé des techniciens du
réseau point chance dont spécialisée
dans la création d'entreprise et des
partenaires du challenge seulement huit
minutes pour présenter le projet de
toute une vie le stress était au rendez
vous pour les participants un petit peu
stress au début et après il nous met à
l'aise donc ça se passe très très bien
et les huit minutes c'est vraiment ça
passe très vraiment vraiment été très
vite moi c'est le sel de la réunion les
épices et les condiments poivre sauvage
de la réunion que tu m'as dit monsoise
au voilà c'est la première fois que je
fais un que je participe à un concours
pour moi pour mon artisanat donc avis
plus 13 ans mais ça va ça s'est bien
passé moi je me sens vraiment su remis
ça et cinq ans en calebasse
donc moi je mise sur ça parce que c'est
un produit utile un vingtième
anniversaire du challenge des créateurs
marquée par l'arrivée d'un nouveau prix
celui de la start up
nous avons décidé de créer le prix de la
start up
c'est à dire le prix de l'innovation le
prix de la modernité quelque chose qui
étonne qui sont en même temps dans l'air
du temps donc tout simplement et vous
verrez que à côté de la tradition
réunionnaise
il vit aujourd'hui le département à
travers le challenge a décidé de primer
ce qui est frappant
comme chaque année les délibérations
n'ont pas été sans difficultés pour le
jury de nombreux projets novateurs ont
été présentés difficile de n'en choisir
que 14 les candidats retenus ont été
annoncés ils sont deux par catégorie et
s'affronteront les 17 novembre lors de
la finale sept prix seront remis ce jour
là celui de l'innovation celui de la
start-up celui du produit pays celui de
la performance le prix de la création
d'emplois celui de l'insertion et enfin
le prix du jury
[Musique]